of the 2015 game narrative summit thank
you so much so much for coming back and
fill in the room I'm told belatedly that
I'm not supposed to be telling you
exactly where we're meeting up later so
ask each other if you're not sure who
knew anyway I won't hold things up
further because we've got as you can see
a magnificent six here to talk to you
about some wonderful things that have
gone on in the past and I'm sure we'll
be going on the future a telltale Game
so I'll turn over something everyone
thank you for coming it's wonderful to
see so many people here welcome to when
story is the gameplay our attempt to get
to the bottom of discuss celebrate
dissect vivisect the telltale games
method style and the magic of it and how
they how they do what they do my name is
Tom Bissell I'm a writer of games and
books and I thought just to start we
would just go down the line and just
briefly introduce ourselves so please I
am Nick brecon not a writer a telltale
peer SRAM red or a telltale Kevin Bruner
the co-founder and CEO Tilton I'm Ryan
Kaufman a creative director and director
of design mark Darren creative director
and designer those introductions were
much briefer than I thought they would
be
I could go on I know much longer so
let's start with a little bit of history
so I'm not quite a telltale OG but um in
2010 during the slate gaming club which
is a convocation of critics to put their
favorite game experiences of the year
and talk about them I included Jurassic
Park the tell-tale Jurassic Park game
anyone give it up for them which I
really enjoy and a couple been this is
to give you a sense of how different
Telltale's reputation was back in 2010
so we were like that point and click
Jurassic Park game but I remember by
playing through it I saw the shimmering
of something really cool and interesting
happening and so by the end of the of
the the 4 episode arc I realized that
holy cow these guys are onto something
really special and interesting and then
so I think I was slightly less surprised
that a lot of people were Milwaukee dead
came up because it seems to me that that
was the crystallization of what you guys
learned on that so I would like love to
hear you guys talk about the
transformative process of what you
learned on that game in particular and
what the Eureka moment was for
storytelling bringing it into from
Jurassic Park and walking dead you let
instead of Kevin yeah I think a lot of
things hey I think Jurassic Park has got
some amazing things in it and it's a
flawed game but if you haven't played
episode 4 of Jurassic Park you should
because there's a fantastic underwater
shark sequence that is top-notch but you
know I think when we started Delta L you
know we love adventure games we love
story in games but adventure games could
kind of word a dark place in 2004 when
we started and we really rolled up our
sleeves with the idea of like okay we
want to find out why these things aren't
working what is it that's weird about it
and every project that we had done along
the way kind of had a creative agenda
a technical agenda and we were
self-publishing so we kind of had a
publisher agenda and I think Jurassic
Park was when a few of those started to
come together like you see little bits
and pieces and our previous work whether
it's more traditional point click
adventure games or the CSI games that we
did the you know we were experimenting
along the way in Jurassic Park we're
like okay let's put the results of some
of those experiments in the same thing
at the same time and like I said it's
you know it's it's a definitely a
milestone along the way there's flaws
but there's also some real gems in it
and I think that's you know one of the
things it was the first game that had
time dialogue that that we did so that
the dialogue you know pacing was a big
thing we're like we want these games to
not slow down they have to keep moving
that was a big kind of compromise that
we thought point click adventure games
had was they would slow down so there's
all these kind of elements come crashing
together on Jurassic Park and then we
did some things that were just a little
too far like we cut walking turns out
that you guys like walking around in
video games so you know but that's I
think I've always been in our are
grounded in this this idea that this
genre that we really loved and really
embraced was relatively obtuse and
misunderstood by like the big gaming
market and we wanted to solve that
problem and so Jurassic Park was really
kind of our first like if we really want
to go to everybody instead of just
people who like adventure games what
would it look like and that was one of
the lead designers on that project at
the time and I was really excited about
experimenting with a kind of gameplay
that we were going to impose we really
had this opportunity to delve into this
rich canon and in this story world that
was amazing
and just kind of looking at it a
surface-level the type of
point-and-click adventure games that
we've been picking in the past wasn't
going to service the story that we
wanted to tell so it really had to
challenge ourselves to kind of think
outside of the box and think of what are
some new ways that we can try to tell
this story that isn't what was in our
comfort zone at the time and so there's
a lot of experimentation and we learned
a lot from from trying these new kind of
swapping characters on the fly and by
taking walking out meant that we had to
explore the environment in a different
way and explore the way where they were
interacting with characters in a
completely different way and a lot of
what we learned out of that went into
what we did with Walking Dead which made
them very successful but we were very
conscious of the interactivity level
that was left out from excuse me from
walking dead and making sure that we're
serving this servicing that in our
future games going forward but it was it
was exciting and challenged at that time
and we made a couple mistake I learned
it off but there was a lot that we
learned and Walking Dead would not have
been possible without having been bold
enough to kind of experiment in that way
and there was still some really really
good storytelling I'm really happy with
the story that came out and that the
characters and the way that the
characters were developed the writers
was all really good stuff and I was very
proud of the team what we put out anyone
else who here has played dressing Berg
okay now go back and look at episode 4
again
available on iTunes so I've talked in
depth to like the creative brain trust
behind games like gears one far cry two
uncharted 2 Bioshock and they all have
something in common which is none of
them had any idea the lightning that
they bottle and the reception of those
games was to almost all of them like a
very pleasant and shocking surprise and
you know these games are not looked at
as some of the premier sort of console
game experiences in the last few years
so I'm curious not did you guys when you
were making Walking Dead I suspect I
know the answer to this did you have any
idea that you had basically figured out
this amazing storytelling method that
was just going to blow up to the degree
that it did no we had no idea i mean we
again like we started telltale so we
could kind of do our own thing and i
think we live in constant fear you know
we were coming off of Monkey Island
which had really high expectations you
know we've kind of dabbled with stuff
that is precious to people and I mean we
were sweating bullets when walking dead
went out because it was so weird we're
like you're not a lot of puzzles in this
there's not a lot of you know Jurassic
Park had regular puzzles and it like
logic puzzles and like we took all of
that stuff out we were like it's just
going to be about the choices you make
and and everybody's going to get the
same ending and this is going to be very
different and very weird and and I think
since then even with the stuff after
that with fables and Thrones and
borderlands I mean Borderlands
everyone's like how are you going to do
a border lands game that doesn't even
make sense so I mean every time
something comes out we are terrified of
how it's going to be received and when
walking dead went was very well received
I think it was hugely flattering and
been really kind of nice to be
recognized for it but I don't think we
were trying to build kind of the world's
you know greatest anything we just
wanted to build something that we
thought was good at the time I was about
very nervous I I did not understand the
concept of story as gameplay so I'm
seeing the story coming and I'm and I'm
understanding it making some choices but
I'm as a designer i'm looking forward to
mechanics for the mechanics of this game
where where the puzzles i can solve and
i'm getting very nervous that people are
going to say there's no gameplay it's
just all story i could just click
through it but it's not just clicking to
it and it took a long time for me to
understand what it is that you're
clicking what it is that you're hooking
into in the story and how you're playing
that game can be the the meat of the
story but when we were making it I had
no idea what we were making I remember
one of the first times that I felt like
this could really work was when we were
experimenting with the choice
notifications you know her she will
remember that and it's that scene when
you're on the porch and he's
questioningly about you know how did you
get here and all this stuff about and
you're trying to hide the fact that you
were writing that in the police car with
handcuffs on and then some of those
notifications started to come in and I
thought oh ok this is the game like
sitting on a porch with a guy trying to
figure out what to tell him so that he
won't kick you out and you're going to
not you know whose clan like that's when
it really clicked for me and I remember
thinking wow the whole game is this you
really have something here and the
team's blew the doors off of it good
yeah i think the writing on this side of
the table writing is represented and one
of the things that was special to is
when when that is the mechanic it all
comes down to the writing the dialogue
in the characters and we did a lot more
actual character development and it was
and we continue to do it but you guys
can talk a little bit about what writing
for design oh yeah I mean you know at a
certain point it's interesting talking
about older versions of Metro games
because you have you know the
traditional inventory systems and you
know puzzles and at a certain point
though like I think the things that you
guys are talking about right now is like
getting to the point where the
characters are the puzzle you know I'm
like how interesting is it to
externalise that stuff and somebody that
feels or you know where that we're
attempting to feel real and you know I
think in terms of our process it really
comes down to marrying like a good
design moment with with a good story
beat and how do we do that how do we
make that mesh and it always comes down
from from the writing angles you know
just how do you motivate the player to
want to do these things you know so we
think a lot about character motivation
and you know how that factors into the
design of scene yeah and I came into it
as a fan so I was a fan of walking dead
season one was interviewing during
episode three hit the Doug Carly moment
in episode three that some of you might
know about reset my machine four or five
times thinking that I broke it and then
just got to jump in and realize that i
love these games it's a like the fact
that telltale makes i mean in most games
you play through and it feels like i go
through this mechanical piece and then
I got the carrot which is the narrative
so telltale games make the carrots so
much bigger all I thought was this is
the good percentage for me I'm glad that
it other people share that feeling yeah
well this brings up my next question
which is the kind of sweet spot I think
you guys are talking about where the
mechanic becomes the choice and where
the character becomes the puzzle because
in every at least once an episode in
every telltale good game I get to the
what I call the oh go to hell moment
when when I'm just presented with some
decision it's just like oh really come
on these are not good choices so you
guys fall in the sweet spot of kind of
low octane character to character
conversations the herschel and Lee on
the porch is a great one but video game
narratives are generally shall we say
high octane and I would love to hear you
all talk about that sweet spot that so
many developers have tried and failed
the hit like what do you think is it is
it the fact of conversations of time is
it the quality of the performances is it
I mean what is that all those things I'd
just love to hear your own sort of I I
personally I think it's caring about the
characters so being a situation we're
actually having to make moral decisions
or decide how you're going to talk to
someone or approach a situation the fact
that I actually care about these these
characters they're just sitting there
staring back at me which I'm so used to
not caring about in the game's best I
think investment in that is the thing
that makes you soft possible and I mean
it really yeah it's a marriage of all
that right i mean like it we spend a lot
of time you know
getting the you know not not me
personally but we have a huge team of
people a telltale whose job it is to
make the performance of you know the
actor of the you know the character
model to match the voice with us and
then you know we'll spend tons of time
you know in the in the voice booth
reppin on you know a couple of lines
over and over again to make sure that
voice matches the character so like that
you know all of those components have to
sort of sync up and for us it's just
about like finding the process that
makes all that really efficient and I
think you know that's that's been a lot
of the recent you know last few years
it's the echo it what Nick saying like
going over things the fine tooth comb is
part of how we get there I think absent
a whole ton of other like driving around
the city type of gameplay we sit there
and we think about each of these moments
and we think about every single choice
that we offer you like those choices
don't happen by accident re really
really agonize over each one and make
sure are we allowing you to say what you
need to say or express what you need to
express as a player but still bring it
down to kind of three essential things
plus silence and that's a hyper focus on
the content and the characters in the
dialogue and the music and everything
that you know certain other games if
you're bigger and you're handling a lot
of those stuff maybe you don't have the
time to do it but I think a telltale
that's our passion that's our focus so
we we spend that time and we're really
really make sure that that those smaller
moments sing just like a big volcanic
moment might you would the absurd amount
that we geek out over every one of those
every time I dialogue choice comes up I
mean excruciatingly ly six people
sitting around a table for days talking
about the words that the display text
star and
what it might mean inside the players
head and what's going on in the
character's head at the same time I mean
the fine-tooth comb yeah arguments over
prepositions yeah it can't be of that
revolutions are important but I mean
when you think about you know our games
are short and there's about you know
maybe like 120 130 of those choices that
pop up at an average episode we actually
offer very little to on how you can put
your imprint and have your personality
be injected into the game like the
amount of inputs that like super mario
64 takes in 60 seconds is probably the
equivalent to the amount of input we
take in two hours input is really
precious to us and learning about who
you are is a player and figuring out
where your head is at then how the
characters in the game might respond to
that and what what's the right thing to
offer that's where most of our energy
goes we spend a huge amount of time
working out the games on pen and paper
or a virtual pen and paper but before
there's a3d where you see lights and
characters walking around we've put a
lot of person months into that with a
lot of really smart talented people from
artist of writers to designers to
everybody before it comes to life on
before we get in the studio and record
stuff every single beat is excruciating
Lee talked about I contemplated them
it's it's really rough on me on these
guys because they have there was so many
fingerprints on there trying to own the
characters and all that and yes it's
awesome it's always awesome yeah he's
lying just now I mean you know it's part
of the job it's just you know I mean if
you're writing in any field you've got
to go into it with the understanding
that you're going to you know if you're
if you're a freelance journalist or
anything you're going to blow away your
own work 10 times we have the luxury of
having you know other kinds of doesn't
it yeah who can get their eyes on the
thing and just make it better over the
course of you know months and years so
you know i mean it's it's it's part but
you know that you know that being said
there's still that exciting moment where
it's just a couple people in a in a room
just crunching out an idea you know and
just you still have that spark moment
where you just have this very concise
idea of like what a scene could be and
and generally speaking ninety percent of
that will still make it through again if
it's good you know and that's exciting
that's an exciting thing that's that
feels unique for freakin you know what
we can take that idea just make put into
the game so fast it i'll tell ya that's
one of the well you're the production
process is fast but that's the other
thing about geeking out about it really
hard as you really kind of start to
understand like where the hallowed
ground is and then it's like when you
find it you're like oh this is going to
be so great and like stuff starts coming
fast but it's it's taken a lot of years
to figure out like when all the
pressures are equally balanced and the
character motivations and where the
player is at and what we're able to
produce and what the actors can bring to
the table and all of that stuff when
like when those things start to resonate
again
yeah Pierre also talked about how much
we care about the characters and I've
noticed from former writers that taught
me it's not just about caring about the
characters it's the respect that they
have for those characters and their the
writers are always super conscious that
these characters aren't just throw away
characters are not just stereotypes that
these are people and you've got to
respect the people in the game and kind
of adding to that is the respect that we
have for the audience people playing the
game that we're not writing characters
are going to do stupid things that you
don't prepare with it does detach you
from the character we believe that you
are going to be caught up in this
conversation that is our games and you
want to contribute and we want to
respect you as well as respect to the
characters and I think that's a huge
part of making those simple
conversations feel real and feel like
they're engaging as well I've you know
most of the stuff I've written for video
games has been collaborative and I found
that just like the absolute best
rhetorical Molotov cocktail to throw at
someone is don't sell out the character
because what the hell you can say I was
you know what well I don't want to do
that you know it's just a but it's true
it's like a true point you don't want to
sell out these fictional people for some
agenda that's not it's beneath the
characters dignity I think it's an
important thing to remember sometimes
it's conflicting because you want a
certain type of gameplay and that
gameplay is going to undermine what the
character wants and we have to find that
that sweet space that you said where it
feels like we're not throwing out the
character for a sake of a gameplay a
moment that isn't necessarily supported
in that narrative got to all make sure
it's all married together in that
perfect bun so the next question is kind
of a can of worms one that I suggest we
open anyway but it's the is it a game
question that plagues stuff like gone
home on one of the spectrum in the order
1886 and the other end of the spectrum
so I don't want to get into it too much
about you guys defending your games from
the accusation but I do wonder
if you when you're developing your
episodes do you ever stop and think wait
there's too much story in this or how do
we get what is the balance for you
whether third games or not we don't
really care that's that's the best
answer leave that's the message when I
started the company when we named the
company there was a hot debate over
whether we should put the word games and
title because we didn't really care if
they were games at that point either but
it's 2004 and the world is Google based
and text based and you're searching for
the new game of thrones game because it
runs on your xbox it kind of makes sense
to be games but like a lot of our
backgrounds a lot of the way that we
kind of deal with it is really just it's
kind of like when you play D&D with a
good DM or we love technology and we
love storytelling and we just want to
mash the things we love together and
make it work and and that's a little
different then then we love video games
as well and I think everybody up here
could do a hell of a job designing a
platformer or any kind of video game
interactive experience we don't have any
disdain for that but our real passions
are character development writing and
playing with computers and software like
when you did when you were a little kid
so we just keep trying to mash those two
things together and gaming is where that
lands that's now we're kind of emerging
we're like tablets you know like I read
books on my tablet and I play telltale
games but I play you know call duty on
my xbox so it's the world's kind of
meeting us halfway a little bit these
days where things don't really have to
be gay
as much but we look at we look at what
we do is interactive scripted narrative
or scripted entertainment or playable
stories all the good words are are
tarnished and tainted interactive movies
interactive TV but I think if you chip
away at it long enough it turns into
something interesting good I just
curious who here thinks four games or
who here thinks we should we here thinks
we shouldn't be called games your rating
on person right so let's get into the
nitty-gritty of what you guys do a
little bit for any us like aspiring
video game writers in the audience I'm
going to let you in a little bit of a
secret which is no matter how much you
plan ahead no matter whatever your
aspirations are for getting stuff done
getting stuff totally worked out in your
own head like a shocking amount of video
game writing gets done in a blind panic
the night before it's going to get
recorded because what happens is there's
so much implementation and that fails
and there's so much iteration and stuff
gets changed on the fly so often and
these these like unavoidable record
dates just sit there looming like one of
those statues on Easter Island and
you're just staring at it and then
suddenly you have to write and it's
getting recorded and it's for real and I
because you guys are still so story
centric and so dialogue concentric I
would love to just know that that
happened to you too so anyone play tales
from the Borland's cool so there's a
scene like where you're underneath the
facility in the arena with Reese and
feel that Reese and Sasha and you're on
the two catwalks you're walking and
you're trying to take out bandit so
that's seeing every written over night
and it's terrifying because it's a first
draft and
not really how you want to approach the
world with your first draft park but
also it's also but the big ideas of the
scene have been the same the entire way
so you have a foundation to build off of
so it feels like you've been working on
versions of the scene in your head for
months so you have something to fall
back on and and I suppose as long as
you're the core of the idea is strong
then you're going to land in a place
that is entertaining and works yeah
you're never do never do your first
draft tonight before that's kind of that
iteration process where like what was
going to happen in that underground
scene went through a lot of different
versions that got explored and rejected
for like it wasn't fun for the player it
wasn't interesting for the characters
and I think you get like in that
scenario you get some momentum and it's
the night before and you're like I got
the perfect thing right so you turns out
to be amazing there's okay it was pretty
good it was okay yeah i mean it's it's
definitely you typically like you know
will write a big chunky like a first
draft run at the episode and and yeah
really like you know we're allotted a
good amount of time to get that done and
the fast iteration is when we r you know
when we're sort of heavy into the back
half of the production and you know
we're doing like I've written I've
rewritten lines in the hand the voice
movies you know but it's because you're
so familiar with the material at that
point that you just can you know and and
you know what it needs to be you can
just read your feel it you're you're
familiar with the with the with the
voice actors at that point you're
familiar with what the scene and what
what the scene can support you know
because that's the other thing is we
have to you know at a certain point
we've built out enough of the game that
we have to kind of account for how much
time is left and what we can do but you
get you know after a couple of a couple
of these games you get better at that
you know
and so you kind of know how much leeway
you have in that last minute dash yeah
well and you mentioned the voice actors
and when you have really strong voice
acting town yeah they bring an element
to the story and the game the characters
and some of those rewrites and booths
are the best stuff yeah that we do and
it's just more collaboration with more
talented people and then point I've done
into a voice recording session before
where our voice actress was super
pregnant so she wasn't going to be
around for the upcoming upcoming
recording sessions so went in with a
handful of lines that she could say for
seeing that hadn't been written yet oh
oh that's tough it worked out but it was
scary that's story Jenga so I've heard
you guys talk about something I find
really fascinating which is a core
conceptual mechanic I guess you'd say
which is a regret and remorse like
asking players just quite simply to live
with the consequences of their decisions
in the games that you make so in
preparation for this i played through
most of your games again and with the
full intention of doing an [ __ ] run
through season one and one good would
lean clementine and even though i know
it's all fake and even though i played
it again and i know it's just a game i
could not be an [ __ ] to that little
girl like his bigby wolf i'm ripping
people's arms off and like I'm just like
I'll do that sure but there's something
about that relationship that I could not
betray so I wonder if seems to me like
regret and remorse are really an
underutilized emotional resource for our
games to try to tap into it seems like
so much about games are about the
opposite of that and if you guys can
talk to that about could you give you
you've given us some truly agonizing
moments and I'd love to hear you all
talk about your maybe your own favorite
personal agonizing moment in the
tailgate
me for actually you know before I just
want to say one thing it's interesting
the way that you talk about playing
through and making the same choices that
you made because I think that that
almost to me feels like in a way like
when I play like a strategy game or
something you know I find myself falling
into paradigms of like what I'm going to
do if I'm playing simcity I know I'm
always going to play it in a certain way
so it almost feels like that might be a
slight defense of our games as games in
a way because it feels like oh that's
just the way that you're going to play
that game you know like we were allowing
you that space to to sort of express
yourself but but yeah it turns of
miserable moment I don't know you guys
have as I favorite agonizing choices I
mean I know the ones that affected me I
mean he obviously that what I picked
Carly I and that around the office
people people are dead guys so the guys
and girls so we're so that puts me in
the minority internally but yeah I mean
the that was as tough choices anything I
had come across in a game so early on
yeah with the with fables I think since
you've looked at me Danny I think it's
fables we almost base the entire season
on regret and remorse like without a
whole world those characters are so
saturated and regret and remorse and one
of the first things that appear and I
figured out was like this whole serial
killer with faith unlike introducing
faith and having her spoilers it's the
onus is on them at this point it's out
there so Marion said it so faith dies
and you know very early on in episode 1
and the rest of the season I mean the
rest of that episode in the rest of
season are really driven by hopefully
the sense of remorse and regret that you
had that you have this this chance
encounter with this woman and she was in
a bad spot and there wasn't a lot you
could do about it you tried to do your
very best which i think is lighting her
cigarette and giving her 50 bucks right
and that was
something that you know Pierre really
brought that like tone and that that
sense of of you know regret and remorse
and awfulness thanks Pierre for slimming
but I need office awfulness good appear
um but that was really i think from
walking dead we learned like yeah that's
a powerful motion for players that
unresolvable thing you like i can't make
this right we learned that on on season
one of walking dead and then going into
fables double down on it and the first
episode and said what if there was a
character whose whole backstory was all
of that and and you want it to like live
inside that guy's skin so that's where
we went with big b and i think yeah i
was happy with how that came out in an
awful way is a we often use the paradigm
of no good deed goes unpunished and we
talk about how the world pushes back
against the player a lot like a telltale
Game is kind of like a shoving match
with the player and when you do that
when you make the world react it's funny
because it's a storytelling game which
and you talk about trying to make the
world react those are kind of pods
there's a lot of a lot of kind of
interactive stuff that are about you
being told a story instead of the story
reacting to you but when we talk about
like trying to make the world push back
and interesting and plausible to the
characters in the world but also really
interesting from the player's
perspective on like the world pushes
back and really kind of strategic and in
interesting ways it doesn't let you get
away with being an [ __ ] if you're you
know like rating like in SimCity
bringing destroy everything that you
built that was kind of fun but if you
try to if you try to destroy what you've
built in one of our games everybody's
sad okay and you don't get the joy of
like I knocked over all my toys
and now I get to rebuild them again we
just don't we feel like if we let you
get away with that then we're not doing
our job of making the characters and the
story world's real and plausible and
then you're kind of hooked back in
you're like oh yeah I can't I can't be
mean to Clementine or abandon the people
of Fabletown or or screw over house
forest or any of these things sent tow
it back to the phone and then sometimes
you have to and then it really sucks
yeah there's a real trickiness to that
because that from a design standpoint we
want you to be able to be and as bad or
or explore the character or whatever we
want to do it but we don't want the game
to ever reflect that your decision was a
bad decision and make you say oh I
played it wrong I want to go play it
right you want to be able to support all
those bad decisions you make and still
look back on it and say oh yes that was
bad bad things happen everybody hates me
but I would have made that decision
again I stand by it and that's really
tricky to get and we've had some some
stumbling blocks I think there was the
Lee and Kenny's relationship in episode
2 when we're able to get Kenny like
really bad at Lee and a lot of players
felt like I've been being nice to kenny
and there's an event here that the game
did that turn Kenny on me and I don't
feel like the game was playing fair and
so it's a very tricky balance to make
make the decision you're making feel
like you want to stay with them as bad
as they are well you also have all those
interstitial scenes right between those
guys that can't really be canted any
particular hostility level because there
I assume that they're the stitching
between any number of choices you can
make right and like getting the right
energy to those scenes I imagine just
must be such a Mindbender that that's
why we specifically recall the tailor
narrative at the beginning of the scene
if you play different playthroughs side
by side n even if you play them back to
back particularly with some of the newer
stuff it feels like the same story but
there's actually a lot of like
individual lines of dialogue and shots
that are tailored to two people liking
you people not liking you to reinforcing
some difficult decisions and some
perceptions that the game may have of
you along the way and and that's where
it gets super subtle but I think that's
where people really respond and where
everybody up here is getting really good
at a lot more detail on like on its kind
of basically the same scene but we can
knock it in an interesting way with a
well-placed camera cut here they're
well-placed line at one place or another
that means you know like if somebody
gives you kind of a if you were a
co-conspirator with somebody and they
give you kind of a crazy glance or
something you know what that means then
you can just put that in a context and
it it's can change the complexion of the
scene entirely and that's kind of the
really highly of old stuff that we're
doing now with Thrones and borderlands
the tailoring is a lot more fine it's
not like do you want to leave in the
daytime or the nighttime anymore it's we
still do that kind of very coarse level
of stuff but the detail stuff is getting
really good as well I often tell my new
designers you know and they ask me well
what is the designer really do it tell
tale like because the writing is so
strong I say think of it this way the
writers represent the characters the
NPC's that the dialogue how it said the
tone of the piece and the designers
represent what does the player want to
do at any given moment so you're kind of
like the players advocate but the two of
those things merging together create
what I call story with a capital s like
that is a merged collaboration between
somebody sitting there with a controller
then everything that like Pierre and
Nick and all these guys have written
like and the performance of the voice
actors and all that stuff comes together
to create you know like this I just have
this idea of this capital has story
that's like something between the two
and it's hopefully slightly different
for every person like Kevin said it's
like this tailored thing so we talked
about the borderlands new telltale
series briefly and not enough hands went
up when they asked who's played it
because it's been my favorite telltale
Game series so far and I just totally
knocked me out and I say this is someone
who has I mean I played the borderlands
games and I enjoyed them enough and you
know like like the games but I wasn't
expecting to just love the world as much
as you guys make me love it and so my
question is you guys do all these
licensed games that come with shall we
say a lot of canonical baggage and I'm
wondering if a world that was relatively
or at least perceived to be baggage free
and that sort of a little bit lighter
economically if that gave you a lot more
freedom to just mess around and pick
around and have a good time so um anyone
who who is a big Borderlands fan would
know that there's a ton of stuff out
there well I will see you guys later and
and but I do think that digging into
that and working with cool people cool
collaborators they let you express what
the story needs and allows you to take
it in two directions that they don't
have an opportunity explorer in the type
of game if they have so I don't guess
like Anthony have been super helpful in
helping us shape the tip story than we
want to tell and also just weird also
hands off when we wanted to do things
that maybe we thought were scary pitches
but they were super into it because it
was
telling a great story within their world
and were great to work with and it's
sort of feel like that's been the case
with a lot of people who work with it's
a lot to be said about inhabiting a
great world his Walking Dead game with a
lot of cannon and its itself there is a
plethora of story that was already laid
out but there was a world that was
largely unexplored and finding our place
in that world just lets us expand what's
already there and create brand new
stories that we can bring brand new
characters in and explore what that
means to have these new characters in
that same world and that's where I draw
a lot of that inspiration from do you
guys find like license stuff and versus
new IP stuff I know you can't make any
big announcements but you did make a
recent big announcement of new stuff
that you guys are up to and are going to
do so my question has to do with with
this type of game that you do and you
seem to have nailed down the style of
presentation the the sort of core
mechanics that you do the tone do you
feel pressure to do a different kind of
game ever or is this the kind of game
you guys want to do forever oh you mean
like what we make a racing game no no I
mean but um yeah because like there's
moments in Walking Dead where users like
shooting sequences sometimes and stuff
like that I'm not asking if you ever get
a shooter but the question is it's funny
I think we really just try to respect
the IP and respect the story right and
you're not going to you know you're not
going to make a Walking Dead game
without shooting you're not gonna make a
border lands game without driving around
and crazy contraptions and big action
sequences as much as our kind of
alongside the respect we have for for
writing and crafting characters and game
design cinematography and visual
storytelling is very revered in the
studio as well and that's why we don't
do over the shoulder chase cams every
single camera set up in a telltale Game
is authored by somebody like we know
every position a camera will ever be in
in any shot in a telltale Game and when
we think about like how do you do
shooting and how do you make it feel
like a cinematic experience you know we
do a lot of QTEs because that's kind of
the state of the art right now for doing
kind of cinematic action sequences but
we're right now we're actually really
invested heavily in trying to break to
see what's on the other side of QTEs
like every we're kind of doing it and
what's on the other side of dialogue
trees like I guess this was a more awful
version my question was is there a way
to play this story that beyond people
talking to each other that you guys like
that's because that seems like a tough
problem to solve yeah like so kind of
the way we've been telling stories is
pretty constrained we before Game of
Thrones and borderlands we were pretty
much single POV we couldn't do all those
storytelling techniques of like you get
to see what's going on in the in the bad
guys layer because then you as the
player would know more than what the
character and that was a problem with
with borderlands and Thrones we've been
able to switch povs and actually if you
play Jurassic Park Jurassic Park
switches povs willy nilly
you complain you'd be playing Jess for
one line of dialogue and then playing oh
geez Jerry Soto Jerry Jerry um but it
was super organic it was just who she
you know that's the interesting thing
for the user to do it's more like a god
game than a character-driven game and
those are you know different ways of us
exploring expanding the storytelling
palette doing it with action sequences
with QTEs you know I personally get
really excited about the idea of God
game story games where you're playing
the story instead of role-playing as a
character in the story but that's like
crazy into the future and we have R&D
efforts over the years Walking Dead came
out of a an R&D effort that was actually
called the zombie prototype before we
signed Walking Dead which was strange
but um so yeah we always play around
with it but I think one of the things
that we we intentionally we don't have a
physics engine we we didn't have a
effects engine until we send up for
borderlands because you kind of need it
to be true to the borderlands universe
so we kind of purposefully tie one kind
of arm behind our back and say we're not
going to do shooting the way everyone
else does shooting we're not going to do
driving the way everyone else does
driving we're not going to do a physics
puzzle nowadays we're like we're not
going to do a logic puzzle we're going
to reject all the traditional stuff and
that's kind of what happened with
Walking Dead we just pulled everything
out and said if it's just all about the
story and the characters in the user
then what do you do and there's a ton of
ground left if ever
that for it's hard to write stories from
a single POV and then we have to povs
and they're both together in one's a
player character that person is kind of
like got to not do the things that the
player is like why are they doing that I
wouldn't do that yeah I'm gonna let a
lot but you know if you look at
traditional games you know they're built
around like big repetitive mechanics
right and that just doesn't make sense
for a lot of the stories we want to tell
right like we're not going to throw a
cover shooter into the walking dead like
what your cover shooting mechanics so I
think what we focus on generally is is
finding just interesting gameplay
moments right and I think that's you
know that's a to me it's a it's almost a
luxury because you can say you know we
have amazing cinematic artists at
telltale like the best in the industry
and you know they just have a lot of fun
just finding you know what could what
can we do with this with the shooting
sequence that feels different you know
then what a shooter would even do you
know I don't know it's a it's sort of
liberating in a way and all those other
genres are so refined when we try to do
aiming oh my god it comes off like first
graders are trying to do it we we don't
have the Unreal Engine and we don't have
you know precision mice and all the
things like that those strategy games
shooting games driving games like all of
those are really really refined and even
if you try to emulate them kind of it
even as a no Maj it's just you can't you
can't even do a proper homage to them
without without really rolling up your
sleeves and doing all the detail work
that's required to make those great so
it's it's it's kind of like we just
throw in a town like we're never going
to be able to do that and if we do it
then the story is going to suffer anyway
so we have to invent a new palette of
ways to describe this
well gentlemen thank you very much we're
going to open this up for some questions
I believe some the time folks in the AL
shirts and back will help you guide you
aid you um let's start right here in the
middle sir yes so really excited I am my
name is Owen I teach at RIT and when my
students tell me they're passionate
about narrative I say have you played
through tell all the telltale games like
crazy right so that's the first place
I'm telling them to go look so I have so
many questions but two are one is I love
if you could break down what the writers
room is like from when you're you get
your first block story how you're
thinking about arks how episodes are
created and then what's the interplay
like we've got little snippets of some
of the dilemmas that you've had and the
preposition arguments but can you give
us a sense of what the writers room
looks like kind of from beginning to end
of an episode and second when you're
looking at portfolios what's really
impressive to you when someone delivers
a writing portfolio or one are you
looking at them and to when you see them
is it you know how many TV credits
they've had or what their graphic novels
are what their games I mean you know
what those two questions would be great
to learn about well it just got out of a
writers room so he's totally prepared
yeah no I mean you know we have you know
at least a two week kickoff for a season
where we get basically every major
stakeholder in the room often the you
know as much as we can the people that
were working with on properties but you
know writers the lead designer you know
that Kevin you know often and just for
two weeks we just grind out you know the
sort of skeletal structure of the season
and then from there it's about you know
basically drilling down in a more
detailed outlines you know putting
together you know one page then a three
page that a five page for each episode
and and that's you know that's a good
couple of weeks at least and then and
then it's you know then it's a focus on
on the first episode which you know can
vary depending on the scope of the
project so yeah anything to add yeah but
I mean I talking about the SEC the
second a second question said yeah I
think the problem is the toughest thing
for a writer Tran stick out is that it's
a needle in a stack of needles right and
especially with really longer form stuff
it's really difficult for the people
that are trying to hire for positions to
read a 90 page screenplay while also
trying to make a game so I think having
a balance of work in your portfolio
having something that's been for us
because we do so much narratives that it
comes from like like screenplay
backgrounds like screenwriting
backgrounds are or something we look to
a lot TV movies but shorter form stuff
too because it's just a thing that will
entice people to actually read it
because it's so hard to grab a 90 page
script and and spend an hour to trying
to assess whether someone's got it or
not when we're looking for an easier
thing to and I would actually also put
emphasis on the first couple pages of
whatever your script is we get a lot of
scripts that the entire first ten pages
is just full of like military jargon or
science jargon or things that just feel
super generic it's really hard to get
whether there's voice coming through
that because it sounds the same in
everything so starting off strong and
kind of putting your best foot forward
even if it's if it's in the 90 page
screenplay the likelihood is that people
will at least get through the first
first 10 first 20 odd i generally look
for two things that are more craft and
are
I lot more talented people than me that
the art but the things that like we tend
to ask the writers as long as they have
to manage exposition and manage
information very delicately there's in a
telltale Game every time we tell the
play or something is a candidate piece
of information it's going to be
important so we can't just monologue
about weird stuff because we might be
misinforming people and there's certain
things that have to be unambiguously
communicated that they can't be too
subtle and that's a giant constraint for
you you know you can come up with a
really great little bit of dialogue and
we're like wow this the cadence is
awesome and they really pull a character
but it really kind of infers that
there's something going on that might be
important later and it's not actually
going on an important later so it's
beautiful but it's compromising the
player experience what do we do with
that and seeing writing particularly
stage play or theatre or film dial you
know standard script like novels are its
novels and short stories are less
difficult to see this in but seeing
people who can wield exposition and
carefully manage information while
keeping character and in the dialogue
sounding real is is super important to
us because the delicacy of like certain
data points that have to be communicated
about where the character is at and what
we're trying to actually tell the player
about what's going on is that that is a
amazing craft and of itself probably the
hardest thing that you guys have have to
do it because you can hear great scenes
with great dialogue in them and you're
like yeah but this kind of means I need
to go find a key / there's something
hidden over there because that's what
they're talking about right you're like
no they're just talking about their
history and what it was like growing up
it's a really challenged sorry really
quick but another thing that the only
times I've for the few times that I got
attraction as
trying to break in and what even work
for me here and this is probably bad
advice but it works for me is I wrote
samples directly for the projects that i
wanted to work on which in movies and
television everyone tells you don't do
that but what's nice about it is you're
almost guaranteed that those people are
going to read it even if it's if that
starts out in a shitty way where they're
like oh so you think you can write this
do you and if you impress them if they
look at that and go [ __ ] this can go
into our game you're way more likely to
get some get them to calling back so
yeah it's at least work for me I was
gonna say the same thing when I applied
to tell tell I actually wrote a twine
game using just season one as a baseline
I wouldn't be afraid to get a little
creative and show you know anybody if
you're playing anywhere you know just
show them that you know you're thinking
about like games you know and that's
always a part of the process applying to
the studio is just like what games have
you played have you written for games
and if you can say yes then it's
definitely a bonus right i mean you know
and even if it feels like a lot of work
sorry but even if it feels like i feel
like this is the thing that people are
here for right even if it feels like a
lot of work what it does get you to do
is write more you know so even if it
doesn't work out you have more samples
now that you can go out with its current
work it's not a screenplay you worked on
five years ago for three years it's
actually actually a representation of
who you are as writer in that moment
thank you yes sir over a look right so I
want to confess that I haven't played a
total game I've always been super
fascinating about what you guys have
done so forgive me that fault and please
excuse of this question doesn't quite
make sense wondered sorry I wonder those
offended I had to release that
clearly you guys have moments where
there's a choice that's necessary and
clearly you guys have a super solid
foundational understanding of what each
character has to do or would do in a
certain situation so my question is are
there any moments in writing a scene or
in figuring out a story where you come
to a choice that a character is making
but you know that the character would
really only make one choice and I don't
want to I'm no spoilers but like for
instance this happens at the end of the
last of us they don't give you a choice
really and it's important and it's a
good decision in my opinion but do you
guys ever get to like yeah I think there
was definitely moments in fables when
there were things that they be had to do
he's a sheriff right so there's certain
things that he absolutely had to respond
to couldn't ignore had to do something
about but then trying to allow the
player to twist the their interpretation
of how we got involved like with faith
like and that's means nothing to you but
like he jumps in the middle of this
fight but then we're trying to give the
player the ability to calm it down or
heat it up a little bit but the fight is
non-negotiable Big B has to split it up
so that does come up at times where the
protagonist you know which is the player
character has to do things outside of
player control and we try to map that as
close as we can to something that the
player can hang on to and something
related to that too is like I read a lot
of I read stuff on the internet which I
probably shouldn't do oh but people
complain that our that our games aren't
branchy enough but we run into a lot of
things where there's a compelling choice
for the character to go right but going
left is bordentown it is just you're
filling in the blanks at that point
you're really struggling just like
something interesting must be it's
really cool like you could choose to
wake I call them or knots it's like I
could choose to go up and punch the guy
in the face or
and it's like that's not a choice that's
that's asking the player permission to
do what we want to do anyway and we
reject that all the time like normally
we just take the choice out or like no
we want to do the cool thing so just
punch them in the face and we'll figure
out something else to do but you end up
if you just get like mechanically
branchy you end up with most of your
energy trying to invent crap to fill in
blanks that you're like I don't know why
Big B would be blonde during around oh
well I guess we could invent something
but all of your energy deals to the
wrong part of the story it goes under
the fill in the blanks part of the story
and when we get into their situations we
just shut it down pretty quick and or
like if it's an or not we're just like
take it out it's not interested thanks
Tom Abernathy is coming up there yeah so
that's all time we have for questions in
this room but these guys will be in room
through thousand for a little bit
afterwards for those of you who haven't
yet got to ask and those of you who
would like to ask more I'd like to ask
everybody just chill for just one second
if you if you don't mind let me wrap
this whole event up briefly if I may I
remember a couple of years ago being
here it was a moment when walking dead
it just come out BioShock Infinite had
just come out titanfall was on the way
and I remember having a strange
sensation about those three things in
sort of you know conjunction with each
other because on the one hand you had a
launch title for a major console that it
ended up had no solo campaign no solo
narrative campaign at all right and on
the other hand you had a game whose
lunar narrative dissonance was causing a
lot of conversation about the role of
story in games and then you had this
other game which in a lot of
conventional senses you know as you said
some people would not consider a game at
all it didn't really have anything that
really constituted combat it did you
know a lot of the things that we
associated with that word weren't
necessarily present and
and I remember feeling a pang of
gratitude to what these guys were doing
because to be honest at this moment I
made reference earlier today to this
being a weird moment for those of us who
do this and at the time I was referring
to some kind of different sorts of
things but another way in which in which
it's a weird moment is to be honest that
story in triple-a is to some degree in
endangered species at this point that
you you know all the big money for
triple-a publishers is in multiplayer
online and that seems to be where
everything's going and so the question
becomes you know given that we know the
market actually loves story and games a
lot where are they going to find it and
one of the things that I'm particularly
grateful to all of you for and to what
telltale does for is that it is is
shining what is for me maybe the
strongest beacon of light as to what one
of the answers one of the possible
answers to that question is and I think
that's really awesome so I'm really
loving dreaming
thanks for thanks for inviting us on the
panel we really appreciate coming here
and talking to all you guys and I want
to add if you want to come and
maniacally maniacally is obsessed about
all this crap with us we're hiring and
find one of these cards and we do look
at every portfolio every every writing
sample that comes in if you are
indisposed to being just almost
borderline destructively obsessed about
stories and games and computers we are
mecca for you please come along pretty
good description most of people in this
room i'm guessing cool well so you know
we may or may not be hanging out at a
place that I can't talk about tonight
ask someone if you don't know what I
mean other than that I want to say thank
you to all you guys because you guys are
the ones who tell us how to make this
something good for you and we listen
really hard so keep telling us keep
coming what and to end as I always take
the end of this event if this was your
first time find someone who's never been
here in the next year and tell them
about it if you enjoyed it and you got
something great out of it and tell them
to come and bring them next year and
let's keep growing it and let's keep
doing more for storing and games cuz
that's what we love thank